four years ago Venezuela's president
Nicolas Maduro was barred from entering
neighboring Brazil so scores of
countries recognized opposition leader
Juan guaido instead as the interim
president
now maduro's left-wing Pier Brazilian
president luisi National Lula da Silva
is welcoming back into the fold
it's hard to conceive that so many years
had to pass without having a dialogue
with the government of a brotherly
Amazonian country a neighbor with whom
we share a 2 200 kilometer border Yahoo
president Maduro lashed out at the
United States and others who call him a
dictator
we can't allow intolerant ideologies to
impose their will extremist ideologies
that exclude those who think differently
Maduro was the first president to arrive
for Tuesday's meeting of South American
Presidents an initiative by Lula to try
to unite the region around common
interest unlike his predecessor Hugo
Chavez Maduro has rarely come to these
Regional Gatherings so it sends a strong
message the fact that he's here that
both he and his peers are willing to sit
down together and work
during this last presidency Lula tried
to create a South American Union
15 years later he's trying again arguing
that in a world increasingly divided
into blocks the Region's voice must be
heard she wrote an article former
foreign minister celso amorin today
Lula's Chief advisor insists that Unity
does not require ideological alignment
of course there will be different views
but we have common interests in many
respects and you have to try to look for
how to search our interests to look
after our interests
in a unified way because like that we
have more strength that's as simple as
that but it hasn't been simple South
American Unity has long eluded a region
that accounts for nearly 10 percent of
the world's population and an even
larger share of key Commodities such as
lithium copper and soy to name a few
that's why many attending the summit are
adamant that if they don't speak with
one voice no one will listen to them
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Brasilia